alors au tour de france au premier il
existait des vignes puisqu'il ya eu un
inventaire dressé par son fils henry 2 à
sa succession à la succession de
françois 1er et il y avait des fermes
avec des carrés ping évidemment c'est
surtout xviiie siècle ce carré de vigne
est apparu sur les plans ou 22,10
arpents pardon c'est fait en gros 6
hectares de vignes étaient plantés au
xviiie siècle et donc dans la plus pure
tradition nous avons replanté cette
ligne alors autre nouveauté les gens qui
veulent maintenant être immergé qui
veulent vivre la vie de chambord peuvent
habiter ici parce que vous avez enfin
habiter occasionnellement dans un temps
limité est ce que vous avez ouvert
d'égypte oui il ya quelques années nous
avons profité de maison
libre dans le village mais parce qu'il y
avait des administrations et qu'on a
relocalisé tout cela dans le château
donc on a créé deux gîtes dans le
village et un dans une ancienne ferme à
l'extérieur du phare un peu plus loin
que le château en forêt et donc ses
gîtes permettent aux touristes de venir
passer quelques jours agréables une
semaine ou un week-end au pied du
château